Okay,
here's the plan for today.
Colonels need to get optimized.
You see this mess?
We're leaking PF everywhere.
Pretty much everything just has to get
fused.
Hey, Anick, welcome. Happy New Year.
Okay.
I'm going to use
Uh, I was actually, it was kind of
funny. Um,
I was getting tempted to work on this
yesterday, but I was too tired and I
knew I was going to let Claude do too
much crap, so I didn't instead.
Ah, okay. So, the container needs to get
rebooted.
If I have modeled 3D dynamics, what
Python module
just visualized dynamics? I don't know
off the top of my head.
It depends on formatted stuff and what's
compatible.
If you just want low-level graphics,
like it's very easy to do whatever ray.
If you want something that's specific to
your application, look up a package
specific to your application.
So this chunk thing here is bad
is what I was getting.
It's actually kind of tricky to think
about.
Yeah, it should be pretty easy for me to
fuse um the seek length one version,
right?
Like I can just not have this chunk and
I can fuse the entire thing.
Uh okay.
What about this one? So this one
log coin value. So this thing can get
fused right
gate hidden.
How is the credit balance too low? The
[ __ ]
Hey, Liberty. Why don't you create a
Discord, dude? We have the biggest
Discord like for RL stuff.
Um, it's discord.gg/puffer.
What are you doing today? We're going to
optimize the crap out of the kernels.
I'm trying to think if we want to fuse.
So, there's a bunch of stuff here that's
slow. Like this chunk operation, the
backwards eating 6%.
I'm trying to think of fuse, though.
It's kind of non-trivial.
actually how does this get used? So this
is
soft plus soft plus.
Can I treat this as an elementwise
precursor?
Okay, we have to be a little bit careful
here.
And not really actually. This is kind of
fine.
That one's actually very easy to do.
We'll start with this.
And then what are we expecting? So this
is going to pass.
You're going to pass one thing
and there's going to be a little bit of
pointer
magic with the addresses on state gate
and
uh this was it the state
and the gate and the hidden.
And then the output is going to be
a single buffer.
Uh so wait do iterate over
be over the output dimension then right
copy pasting hold
uh you will see the exact way that I use
stuff
I pretty much don't ever want this thing
to produce code that is different from
how I would write it if that makes
sense.
So if I'm writing like substantially
different if I'm producing substantially
different code because I'm using this
it's very bad
in D lab that has published papers at
nerves are you excited by the stuff
they're doing in this
hidden gate prod.
So we don't want to call this hidden
Well, if you're excited by the stuff
they're doing, then cool.
If you're going to be there and you
don't think you're going to learn
anything and you're just going to be
giga depressed then no
Yeah. So we get that we just reconstruct
the inputs, right? This is exactly what
I would do.
Think I've been getting paid. They
promised to do a lot of handholding.
Graduated this graduated what?
Graduated undergrad or graduated like
cuz apprenticeships are very good but
the people that you're like the guy
you're apprentice to actually has to
know what he's doing.
any good kernel debugging tools?
So, what I did, Tim, is I just spent the
last day or two building this.
So, now we have profiles for all our
kernels. It's a pretty big script and
this runs through NSIS and this
basically checks every single thing that
we need.
Undergrad
I'd only take it if you're impressed by
the guy and you think you can learn
stuff from him.
If you find their work impressive and
interesting and think you can learn,
then like go for it. Um
if not, then like find something else to
do.
is optimizing the crap out of kernels.
We have to fuse a lot of stuff.
interface being [ __ ] is really annoying.
Output gate.
This is actually better because then we
get to use our sigmoid on the out.
That's pretty good.
Mor thinking machines. Yeah, 5K is but
I mean it's like if you if you think
you're going to enjoy it, then do it,
dude. Just don't make yourself
miserable.
Like I took one shitty startup
internship that I absolutely should not
have taken and that was not very
valuable. So
you don't you definitely don't want to
just take something to take something.
You can do a lot with three months,
right? Like will you learn more from
these guys than you would learn on your
own?
Right? If you just like set yourself up,
I'm going to go teach. I'm going to go
learn whatever it is for the summer.
Would you learn more on your own or
would you learn more with these dudes?
Right?
Is Opus helping? Does it take much
steering? Uh, the thing is like
it doesn't take much steering because
I'm not letting it do huge chunks of
stuff.
B * H
which is the hidden.
Yeah. So it should be over the output
dim, right?
Uh, so Major, this is like the ideal
test case because this is
I have like a bunch of different things
hooked into this and it's very
boilerplatey
and it's very easy to make errors on the
boiler plate
and it's like unavoidable boiler plate.
Like you should not have boiler plate on
the vast majority of stuff you do. In
this case, it's actually unavoidable
because of um wall torch mostly.
So like literally all that this is doing
is essentially
taking this operation and putting what
looks like the exact same code into the
kernel
instead of being at this level. So I'm
basically just moving stuff from one
layer to the other.
But doing that manually is very very
obnoxious because of like in an ideal
world it would be set up in a way where
it's not aggressively [ __ ] to do stuff
with. Um and I often think it is worth
setting it's worth spending the time
improving interfaces but in this case
there's not a realistic way for me to do
it. So this is next best thing
I will say you definitely want to have
you definitely want to get your comp to
come from,
you know, your actual AI work as quickly
as possible if you can.
and you'll get paid much more and you'll
have much more time to actually improve
your skills.
declaration changes.
You see the amount of boiler plate. Like
there's also this output. Like yeah, I
would totally forget to just mess with
this stuff.
use me memory leaks are like
that's not actually a bug class that's
that matters
and it's very easy to not have memory
leaks
academia from your experience student
debt. Am I being too ambitious? So,
Benjamin, I only ever recommend people
do a PhD if they want to do a PhD and
they know that they want to already. Uh,
you do not pay to do a PhD.
You get paid during your PhD. You don't
get paid very much, but it covers basic
expenses.
Okay. I don't think this is a true 9 mil
because I think we have stuff commented.
Yeah. See, we have all this stuff
commented.
Let's just rebuild this so we get a
realistic estimate out of this.
But 9.3, if we could get rid of the um
this is not even the backward pass, by
the way. This like this stuff should be
pretty cheap, but it just isn't.
Okay, that is still a little bump
though. 7 seven up to eight. Yeah,
that's a little bump. That's very nice.
Okay. And oh, did we uh Hang on. But are
we not converging now?
Yeah, we're not converging anymore.
Crap. Okay.
Okay, we know that this thing's broken,
right?
Try this again.
I'm actually surprised that it broke my
kernel. That's like a That was a pretty
easy change.
Let me see if I can spot it.
Huh?
Dude, what the [ __ ] did this [ __ ] do?
Hey there, welcome.
Yeah, we got the current stream.
And then here's the tilder which is the
same thing. And we've used this before.
I'm not seeing the
Yeah, that will do it completely.
I didn't notice that. Screw up.
This is why it has to be a verifiable
because it's I wouldn't make this
mistake but it would be very it's very
difficult for me to see this mistake
because like this is like it's
completely messed up. You can't put the
you can't put the output gate on the
hidden obviously.
Do you have tests?
Yeah, I have tests.
It's actually better though that I run
the test myself most of the time because
it takes forever and just chews up
tokens.
Uh, it does need to be a vector out,
right? Yeah,
that's fine.
Uh, so we're fusing everything today,
Jess.
That's the objective is we're going to
fuse all the kernel ops
because essentially it's just death by a
thousand cuts. Like every single little
thing in here is just slow and the only
way we're going to get around is by
having one big kernel.
It's not just the kernel launch times
either. We already have a graph.
It's kind of just brutal.
I imagine we'll probably get something
off of not having to call contiguous,
too.
I mean, Torch just does so much crap
behind the hood.
Yeah, we do. The same as before.
Perfect. So,
what was the speed of that? It was seven
78. Yeah, that's good.
7.8 8 mil, guys. 7.8 mil.
2.2 mil to go.
Okay.
This is where it's tempting to let Claw
do too much [ __ ] Um, I'm going to
let it help so I don't screw up the the
porting of these ops into the kernel as
well as the derivatives of the
individual ops.
Um, but I want to make sure I have this
set up correctly. So
I think what we can do
I think
is that we can fuse these in to
I think we can just fuse these into the
scan kernel basically.
It's a little sketchy honestly.
It's a little sketchy.
Opus no kernel. Again, I'm not ever
asking it to like make the kernel
faster. I'm asking it to do a very
precise manipulation.
Just because I'm using the tool doesn't
mean I'm vibing crap all of a sudden,
right?
Let me make sure that the thing I I'm
thinking of makes sense first.
Is this a simple pure element wise op?
It is right.
I'm going to make a quick commit
before I do this because it's going to
be risky.
So there there are kind of a couple
places of uncertainty here. Um you lose
an axis of parallelism.
There's also numerical stuff that can go
wrong.
But I'll show you what I'm thinking of
in a moment. I think it should work. I'm
not positive.
Go.
Okay. So,
If I do it this way, is there any
downside? So, I'm basically thinking
like we just tack this kernel on to the
uh the front of
of the fuse scan op.
So like right here you'd call it.
This would save me bandwidth. This would
save a lot.
Actually, I think if I do it I think if
I do it in stages, I can describe this
as a very simple set of modifications
where it's not going to take too much
control.
If I fuse these two together first,
right?
C++ docs are tort hard to navigate.
Yeah, cuz they're basically
non-existent.
Did you figure it out from the source
code? Uh, partially some of that. Yes.
And then this is actually one of the
other main reasons why I'm using the
model is because they've read the torch
source code. So, uh, the models are
actually better than the torch docs.
most of the time.
There have been several things though
where I've just spent like four hours on
an undocumented bug and then fix it and
then spend four hours on the
undocumented bug. I pretty much had two
days straight where it was just like fix
undocumented bug after undocumented bug.
But hey, this is what it's going to take
in order to get Puffer to be fast. Like
we're going to hit 10 mill steps per
second. I think we can do it today.
So I think what I'm going to do is I'm
basically going to have it use my exact
existing code and just port it from a
kernel into ops cu. So we have just like
these set of element wise ops
and
I think that this can be done as like a
very small change essentially. This
going to be like a very small thing.
Drinking coffee. Nope. This is my own
recipe.
This is 66 gram of protein in a hot in a
mug of hot chocolate.
with no added sugar. The recipe is two
cups of whole milk, two scoops of
unflavored protein powder, two t uh two
heaping teaspoons of cocoa powder, and a
bit of cinnamon.
It's about 550 calories, 6 uh 66 g of
protein.
You missed stream yesterday. I didn't
miss stream, my guy. I don't stream
every day.
Not in this block of work. In the
current block of work I'm on, I've got
more streams that are just all day long,
right? But the trade-off is that I have
some days where I do a bit of client
work in the mornings and evenings and I
take myself to the gym for a good two
hours.
We're going to see. This will be
something of a test for Opus. I think it
should be able to do this because
So, let me explain what this is cuz it's
like uh if you don't know what you're
looking at, this can look like something
very different. So what I've done is
I've described a very small precise
modification
uh that is very fiddly to do manually
because there are basically there are a
bunch of places that you have to change
stuff with the way that CUDA code is
laid out and bound to torch and it's
very easy to screw up. So I've
essentially described a very precise
change. I know pretty much exactly what
the code should look like, but my
expectation is it's going to be faster
and more accurate to apply this sort of
use uh cloud to apply this template
rather than do it manually.
So, I'm not like going to be surprised
by the output of this, right? This is
like I'm describing precisely the opt to
do. Um, and this is about the level that
I'm liking using it at.
Uh, Lance, the topic for today is
optimizing the crap out of our kernels.
We're going to hit 10 mil.
Okay, so this is exactly what we wanted,
right? So, it took this is the exact
transformation that I described, right?
Remember I said we're going to take this
kernel and we're going to put where is
it? This kernel and we're going to move
it into an element wise hop. So instead
of having a templated function here like
this with all this indexing, we now have
an elementwise op added to the cu
header. And then the same thing for
backwards.
Little screwy with the pointers how it
did this, but I think I'm fine with
that.
You kind of have to do this because um
yeah, you have to do this because you
can't get multiple returns. I actually
didn't think of this when I was
originally writing my um
uh when I was originally writing these
kernel headers, but actually this makes
a lot easier to do a various number of
element wise ops if you're allowed to
have just single element pointers.
I like this.
Carmarmac is reading one paper a day. Uh
that is a good thing to do when you're
getting into a field for sure.
That's pretty much what I did when I
started in um in AI.
You know, as I've gotten um as I've
spent more time in the field, I no
longer think that that's a good use of
my time.
like one to two hours worth of focused
uh like actual focus time per day to
read a paper is a very heavy cost.
Okay. Okay. So it is already trying to
do the modification.
Uh yeah log co this is going to get
computed now in here
subsequent time steps
you compute from the get. Yes.
Okay. You get your gated inputs. This is
all fine.
I mean, Carmarmac is great, obviously,
right?
I genuinely think if he just like came
over and tried to do the RL stuff the
way that I'm doing it, he'd crush it.
Um, the approach he's taking with
Sutton, I I'm not a huge fan of. I think
obviously whatever it is, he'll execute
on it fantastically,
but I think that the approach I have
here, which is funny enough, it's a lot
more similar to what you'd expect out of
uh people with like a very heavy PF
engineering mindset. I think this is the
way to go overall in in RL.
Read some on the weekends depending on
how X talks. Eh, I don't I especially
don't like reading newspapers.
Okay, so we have log co and values
forward.
I think I can allow this for now. This
is going to be slower as written. It is
simpler. So we'll we this is going to
have to get cached though, right? Like
there's no way you possibly allow it to
do this.
So, uh, if this works, this is going to
be slower than before most likely
because we have not had this cache, but
we will cache this before we're done.
This is just signature update.
This is also going to just be signature
update.
And you have to update the launch
signatures, the module signatures, uh
the prototype signatures in the C++, the
exposed to Python, the test. Like it's a
lot of [ __ ] to update.
Context is respected. Uh Lance, I I did
it for this one. For most of the
changes, I don't actually need to do
that because I'm not using it for large
enough changes.
I'm pretty much never asking it like
implement a function that does this in
English, right? And like describing a
precise transformation to apply to the
existing code.
This honestly this might even be too
much. Like I might try this for a few
weeks and decide this is too much.
Or I think what's more likely is I
decide that this is kind of fine for
this code base, but like if I'm writing
custom Sims for instance, I want to use
it way less than this.
Is this the launch? What's this? Oh,
this is just the module function. This
is fine.
No, don't allow all edits. Make this
change.
Okay, now we get the fuse scan. This is
gone.
This is fine. It respects this and we're
good.
Well, this is expected to be slower
here, Tim.
This is an initial thing, but what I've
done is I did a whole bunch of manual
profiling of stuff. Um, I built a bunch
of tools, and it really does seem to me
like you just got to fuse everything.
I will build it myself. Thank you very
much.
I wouldn't say it's cleaner because like
these are ops that you kind of it would
be nice to have them be separated. So
it's like very very tightly coupled. Um
and it's going to make it slightly more
annoying to experiment with
architectures. I think we can minimize
the overhead of it though. So I think
it'll be fine.
So if this even trains, we expect it to
be slower.
H, it's faster.
The completely unoptimized version is
faster.
Well, then it's going to be way faster
when we're done with it. Cool. Uh, yeah,
that's a sub 15 second solve, guys.
That's a soda.
Yeah, that's soda again. Okay, cool. Uh,
let's commit this
20 mil is actually incredibly difficult.
I think I'd have to rewrite I think I
would have to rewrite torch to get 20
mil at this batch size. Uh we can
actually get 20 mil right now though
just by increasing the batch sizes and
stuff. But that's like that's kind of
cheating.
8 mil per CPU per second. Uh we can do
that for sim lance. No, this is eight.
This is training speed on a single GPU.
Yeah, this is train speed on a single
GPU. Oh, one moment folks.
cool. Let's go check what we're doing
next.
uh the gate the output gate super easy
to scan right like diffuse Yeah.
This is a super easy modification.
The one that's a little bit trickier is
the chunking fusion.
G flops we pull in. Honestly, it's
probably still bad, man. Everything is
super me bound uh memory bound and
there's still like tons of little chunks
of overhead everywhere. It's just that
they're getting harder to cut out.
Shall I make the mistake of checking X
and seeing uh the internet being on fire
again?
Let's see.
Anything good?
Yeah, PyTorch on CPU is super gigab
bloated. Like it's not even remotely
close.
Why do we have a million replies?
Oh, did the stupid post blow up? Oh,
I just saw that the stupid post. Uh,
yeah. All right.
Funny.
Doing the same using MPs SCS and share
memory. We can for the end badger buying
buffer really good. The M's a little
more expensive than yours. We've got
plus - 12 kilob ops. So our lamps our
new um
so our new buffering of uh host device
transfers will help you a lot because
now we're buffering the transfers to
GPU.
That'll help a lot.
It's substantially better than the uh
the Puffer 3 architecture for that.
Uh, fine. It can do this at once if it
wants to, but I have to check it more
carefully. Have merged main. Well, 40 is
super unstable, Lance. I didn't tell you
to like just use it. Um, I'm saying that
the new architecture though once we have
it fully done will be substantially
better for that.
net safety.
Uh I'd honestly I'd assume that they're
just a bunch of numerical screwy things
if you're using uh any of our new models
yet.
I mean, this is still a work in
progress, man. Everything needs custom
kernels is the annoying bit. Like the
the new model is actually quite simple
if you look at minro
like it's not that much code, right? But
the thing is this is just so
unbelievably slow without kernels. even
if you cuda graph it like you just throw
away half of your performance.
So, if you want a more stable version,
you can just use this and see if this is
more stable without the kernels, at
least for these ops. Um, until I've had
time to fully test, but you'll lose half
the perf.
Agile RL Collab.
Oh, yeah. I've seen some of their stuff.
Are they the ones that are doing
language models now?
Yeah, they got themselves some clients,
so I guess they're alive.
Good to them.
They got invested. Push by money
mission. Yeah. This is why I don't take
investments, man.
If you just don't try to grow faster
than you do organically, you don't have
these problems.
Okay. So, what this is here
scan result.
Yeah. So, what this is here is this is
now taking uh it's replacing this chunk
operation. This is the goal, right? We
want to replace the chunk because the
actual the chunk forward creates a cat
backward and the cat backward is uh like
700 SPS overhead.
What would you like the com to help you
in the 40 open source? Uh catch all the
dumb stuff that I've basically like
catch all the dumb stuff that I've
broken and help me get like minimal
fixes and patches without trying to
creep new content into the release once
it's stable.
The goal for puffer 4 is that we just
have everything super fast. We have the
best baselines on all the M's. The M's
are clean. Like we just basically want
to have this be the super fast, super
clean version of Puffer where we can run
100,000 experiments and start
aggregating results from everything. I
think we'll probably do it in a way
where the community can even contribute
results as well on new environments. So,
we build up this like this big dashboard
of experiments that really really tell
us how everything scales in RL. I think
that the the goal for this is to have RL
be faster than ever by about at least
3x. To have uh certain settings of
Puffer be 10x plus faster. Like small
batch sizes and other sort of academic
experiments are going to be way way way
faster than 3x. And then we want to have
a giant data set of experiments
as well.
So, I think that like
the easiest thing for the community
that's not the the easiest thing for the
community, unless you have experience on
this type of stuff, uh, is to help on
like really solid experiments and
benchmarks. Like, believe it or not, the
science side of RL is now going to be
more accessible than this stuff. So,
it's actually going to be pretty easy to
contribute to the science in Puffer 4
because you will just need one GPU to
run thousand experiment sweeps.
So I think that's probably the best
thing is like helping on experimental
side and like starting to get into the
science which is cool because in puffer
3 like the community could get into the
uh the end building side but it was
harder to do like more experimental work
because you still need a few GPUs and
now it's going to be that the community
can community can actually do
experimental work.
It'll be nice.
And I don't think it's unreasonable to
ask um even for architecture stuff, I
don't think it's unreasonable to expect
the community to be able to edit this,
right? Like this is basically the same
as the torch. Obviously, I don't expect
people to touch their cars.
The sigmoid grad here is a little iffy,
but I'm pretty sure this is Yeah, this
is derivative of sigmoid.
I'm going to clean this up into a really
nice ops library.
I think once we see the PF on this, I'll
decide how much of my time I want to
spend uh cleaning up this kernel today
versus
uh looking for other remaining PF
optimizations.
We'll see how close we get to 10 mil off
of this.
We could hit it, especially once we do
the uh the catching.
We might hit it.
And again, this looks like a bunch of
changes, but this is literally just the
module binding.
So, this is just torch being a ton of
code for no reason.
This will actually shorten our test
which is cool.
This is basically what it'll be. So you
can see here
this whole path. So this is false. You
get here the entire path. It's just one
linear layer and then one kernel for the
gate
which means that we no longer have uh we
should no longer have tap backwards
in the profile. Well, which was 6%
before as well as some additional memory
bandwidth overhead
8.6
fellas.
Today might be the 10 mil day, Spencer.
We're at 8.6 with some awful, awful
stuff in the kernel.
All I have to do is I have to be
vigilant and not I have to just be
vigilant and not give too much control
to claude and make a mess
because this is basically something
where it would take forever to do this
manually. But I have to make sure that
we still end up with like solid kernel
code.
Oh yeah, it's 20 mil on eval by the way.
So the forward passes are 20 mil steps
per second here. You can go watch that
again. Let me the restroom real quick.
Oops.
Break out in 16 seconds.
Yeah, it'll be
It needs to be 10. I actually think
we're going to get um the thing is we
have not reoptimized hyperparameters and
puffer now has a totally different
profile of uh fast configurations than
it used to have. So I expect that just
rerunning hyperparam will get us 10
seconds but we'll see. We have to get
like apples to apples speed up before we
do that.
Okay.
Um,
right. We want to run improv.
So if we want to see how fast this
kernel is,
my hope is we see like 20% overhead in
this kernel or something ridiculous and
then we just go, "Yeah, we make this
kernel faster, we win."
But I think we're still going to see
something of a long tail.
I think we're still going to see
Okay.
Uh, it's going to take a while to
generate the profile trace.
So the other thing folks um
we have like two million step per second
overhead in the optimizer
and I don't mean the backward pass I
mean the optimizer
like after you've done uh lossbackward
optim step takes 2 mil SPS off. That's
kind of an issue.
I don't know what to do about that one
though.
That one's kind of a pain.
it's kind of crazy to think that this is
still real.
Like you can see right here, this four
layer network. I didn't mess with the
settings. It still works.
Get rid of what?
You can't get rid of Muan. Muan's really
important.
We ran pretty comprehensive experiments.
It's a big upgrade to Adam and it's not
even it's a chunk of the overhead is
because of Muan, but like a chunk of the
overhead is just because of the way that
you have to apply the uh the tensor
updates with torch.
we got our kernels. We got all our
stuff.
Hey, this is exactly what we wanted.
Look at that.
So now we have the slow thing is
actually just this kernel.
Look at that.
So we just have our kernel here eating
20%. This is what I just said would be
the best case scenario.
It's actually kind of awesome how well
that just worked.
Because this is Matt Moles.
I actually don't know what these are.
So, we'll have to figure out what like
where these extra element wise are
coming from all these because that's
another 25%. But then right here, we can
kill this
SGD outperform. We want in on smaller
nets. No, it doesn't.
Unless there's some SDG
that you mean, but SGD, no, it does not
outperform. head shed.
Muan was pretty instrumental in um in
Puffer 3. So unless you have like some
really compelling experiments, I mean
you can go ahead and run the experiments
on Puffer 4, right? Once we have it,
that would be very easy to swap. But I
highly highly doubt that you just
vanilla SGD is better. I think that's
Yeah, that's trolled.
Okay. So, 20% overhead
and 15% I'm 21% overhead.
I think we're going to apply one quick
optimization maybe
and then we're going to do
some heavier stuff.
was adhesives on why smaller video
uh because there's only so much noise in
the gradient Spencer.
So once you increase above a certain
batch size like you already have a
perfect estimate
and 30 p. Okay. So completely different
setting from what we're doing. Cool.
I will pay attention when the GPT2
speedrun starts using SGD instead of
Muan.
So, this is just the easy optimization.
I think the rest of the optimizations
are substantially harder. Um, this one's
easy.
like this here. This should be um like
5% overhead for no reason right there.
and yeah that's fine. So this is again
all this is doing now we're caching this
output. Yeah you see it's just gone from
here
um wherever it was cached.
Now we have all this branching on all
this frap
that we got to figure out.
I think this should get us above 9 mil
though.
We will see.
Some of these flags are a little
suspicious.
But the same
Non radiant base. No,
doubt it.
At the very least, you have to go pretty
far off what is done. Um, if you want to
play with that stuff,
Okay. So, interesting.
I'm actually very surprised that's not
like immediately.
Smallest learning rate tiny tiny
that's very weird Spencer
really
for Mulan that's really weird
like if you're making the networks way
bigger then maybe
that seems very odd to me
I think we are going to have to just
spend some time optimizing kernel.
Well, we can actually we'll have it fix
the um fix up the test first.
Yeah, we'll fix the test so we can
actually get the timings first and then
we'll do it. That way I don't have to do
a perf test during training.
Oh, we did take um we did take 5% off.
Cool.
So, where the heck these come from?
Where the heck these? Yeah, there lots
of these little kernels.
Yeah, this will massively change the
test in here.
Okay, we update all these. We update our
malics.
Okay. I can tell it's only like 11:30
and I'm already starting to get lazy on
this. So, I got to be more disciplined.
Um,
this one is fine.
What was our uh our kernel test? Oh,
yeah. Python
That's going to get fused.
Today could be the 10 mil day.
It could be the 10 mil die.
For anyone who's new around here, I
stream all my devs. I'm typically making
RL go fast and be sane. Sometimes I'll
go dev as well. Uh if you want to
support my work for free, feed the
puffer star on GitHub. We're almost to
5K. It'll be so awesome to hit that. I
work on this at least full-time, so it
helps get the word out. We have all
these M's that you can test right on the
website, too. Some are games, some are
not. Games are nice for testing, but I
can do way more than just play games.
All right, what are we doing here? Opus
fuse test. Quick update. Yes. Yes. Good.
Correct.
Mal.
Okay. We'll double check these in nich
when we go to do numericals, but we're
not doing numericals yet, so that's
fine.
open source or has the same scale? No,
because nobody has that number of GPUs
open source.
Uh we can get very close to the same
data scale though. Like with Puffer, we
have even with Puffer 3, we have on our
like neural MMO3 environment, we train
that for 12,000 years worth of SIM. So
we're in the ballpark of the amount of
data that they use, even though we have
um way smaller training hardware scale.
And I think we should be able to exceed
it in the next version.
Like we should actually be able to train
agents on more more observations than
OpenAI 5 did, though with much smaller
models.
You'll still get some awesome behaviors
out of it, though.
do this and then this just needs to get
ported around. This is fine.
Okay, check that. I'm going to grab a
drink and we will be
right back.
That's funny. All right, I'll be right
back.
reference implementation. This has the
chunking.
This does not allow you to have an
expansion factor anymore.
Reference implementation for Q scan.
Yeah. Again, it just puts this into
here.
it chunks.
It's fine.
I'm going to feel way better though once
I actually go through and have this like
and uh get it cleaned up nicely.
uh I think it just deleted something it
shouldn't have. That's
interesting.
It's not even there. Fine.
And then we should be able to run our
test,
right? Which is this one. We don't need
this.
Oh, that's a slow backward pass.
67. Yep, that's solid.
Cool. Uh, we don't even have the fuse
loss in there yet. And we're still fast.
So, that'll be plus a little bit once we
get it.
82 and 107, right?
Let's make sure real quick.
Let's make sure we still train.
We should be fine.
But now we have a fast benchmark
standalone for that kernel.
You know why? I just went and got myself
a cold drink instead of getting myself a
coffee.
We'll get a little bit of optimum done
and I'll actually go get myself some
caffeine.
Uh.9
Got 12. Holy 13 seconds. All
15 full solve. Perfect. All right. So
Now I have to look at this manually
multiple times a day as standard on a
good day.
I mean, it's more just like a lot of the
work that I do that seems very boring is
setting up to be able to do this,
right? So, when it looks like stuff
happens very quick, it's because there's
been a lot of work put in uh ahead of
time to make this possible.
team making.
Wait, no background in RL. Leading a
small team making a designing collective
intelligence system currently enabling
it to create popular BMS. Any best
practice is what makes a good ad.
Um, keep it simple, keep it fast, avoid
all the pitfalls that I have listed in
the tutorials on the docs. Reference
some of our higher quality code bases
for it. Price of complexity in RL is way
higher than the price of complexity
elsewhere.
Uh,
there is some stuff on like designing
good ops and action spaces that you can
find in some of my articles on X. Pretty
much through most of my material I've
covered like environment design
practices.
Okay. So,
these two kernels here,
I think we can pull another 500k to 1
mil off of these.
Like, look what a mess these have gotten
to be.
First time step, use log state.
There's something I want to check real
quick.
Yeah, this is the C++ one, right? How
would you learn C if I could start over?
Um, well, I'll tell you, Carter, the the
main thing that just screwed me over.
So, when I was taught C in undergrad,
uh, one, the professor was terrible,
but two, the biggest thing, if I had
like the single biggest thing, all
right, they didn't tell me that an
address sanitizer exists.
Like C with GDB and an address sanitizer
is good. C with like I don't know it's
seg faults I don't know what to do to
fix it is terrible.
So just like basic compiler tools for
debugging.
I want to see what this I want to
actually understand what this pad is
doing
because it is kind of wonky now
Okay. And then
this one gets log collifs
then padded at the end.
main thing I see is all the branchiness,
right?
Okay. So what I want to do is I want to
start isolating you know exactly why
this kernel is
uh is slow right. Where's the curve cing
coming from?
I think that you can do it just like
comment this one, keep this one.
80 micros for right.
I actually bet that this is not going to
work. I bet that funny enough this is
the first spot that it's not going to
work because this is the first spot.
This is actually the spot where I would
want to use my judgment a little bit
more.
So this shouldn't have removed any of
the actual ops really, but this did
remove a bunch of branching. So we want
to see if this messes um well if this
fixes the PF.
If it does then we just have to do
branch optimization. Otherwise we have
to do ops optim optimization.
I mean we don't just have one main use
case right we do RL generally
so Puffer builds the fastest RL tools
out there uh we have a big suite of test
environments
we build a ton of info we do algorithm
research search and then professionally
we build custom sims in a variety of
different domains and apply our tools to
them. Now we're able to train at
millions of steps per second on a single
GPU. So we're really just able to any
problem where we can build a high perf
SIM, we can just crush a ton of data
really fast.
Okay. So, good. We didn't spend too much
time on this, right? Because this
actually didn't help. You see,
it's actually the branchiness didn't
make a difference.
when one you adding to finance end I
keep forgetting Jess the one that we're
adding is so basic though like the way
cooler one is the commerce M that's
already open
so machine learning researcher for DARPA
So, I want a highly funded startup.
You can go try to start one. Um, the
problem at the moment with RL is like
there's so much hype around language
models that if you try to go get any big
amount of money,
uh, for the most part, investors try to
steer you into doing language model
crap, which is why we're not taking
funding
because we don't want to do that.
Okay, let me see what else this would be
then. If this is not the
issue
commerce,
no, it's there. It's We tweeted it,
Jess. It's not in puffer main.
Um, it's the archive end.
What types of Sims have you've made? We
have one in commerce. We've got a couple
in finance. Um, we've done stuff for
animation before.
We've got like a little bit of defense
adjacent stuff. And we'll likely be
doing a bunch of game stuff in 2026.
Use Puffer for robotic arm. If you have
a a compatible SIM or you're building a
compatible SIM, then yeah, of course.
Okay. Where is where is our compute
going?
How the launch args look for this thing?
Do we just have stupid launch ars?
Seek size
of total wait
B
time page.
Yeah, carpole is not a good end. It's so
simple you can solve it with anything.
Pong is also too simple. It seems that
so from our work um breakout is the
simplest end for which your results are
usually meaningful elsewhere.
We can just go through the block sizes
real quick, right? There's no harm.
Weird. That didn't make a difference,
right?
Oh, well, it's definitely worse if you
make it small.
Interesting.
Briefly catch up viewers on what you're
working on. Objectives. Can't really see
the text.
Well, it's a problem if you can't see
It should be streaming this at 1080p.
So, if you're not on your phone, it
should be visible.
Let me go look.
You can totally see the text on this.
You're not on a phone.
Um,
yeah. So what we're doing though at the
moment anyways
we are working on optimizing the custom
kernels that are needed for this network
architecture.
Uh it's an architecture that should be
very fast but it's not fast naively like
it needs a bunch of custom kernels.
And it turns out that you really just
have to fuse all the operations together
into big single kernels to make it
usable.
And that's what I'm doing at the moment.
We are up to 8.8 million steps per
second training. We're trying to hit 10
mil today.
I think pretty much from here
we
have to look at either precision or
operations. Oops. There might be a few
things we can change. We'll see.
Precision of this op's important though.
Let me see.
Yes, I'll find you the end. It's not on
puffer like it's a client end but they
open sourced it.
Oh, actually
there.
quential nature.
Um,
Like, fair enough, my guy.
I didn't think of it this way. Let's try
it like this. We comment this function.
Yeah.
What's this?
Because it could be way way more
overhead here than it was before.
This is FP32.
Ah,
yeah, that's it.
Okay.
Okay, so that's sketchy
cuz so then outside of this the whole
rest of this function is 30 micros.
for the scan, which is not bad.
And the chump.
That's not bad.
What are you working on today, Koko? We
are fusing all the kernels together. Um,
well, all the main group kernels
basically.
There's a lot of overhead
and it turns out we can just view stuff.
We're already at 8.8 million. I think we
have a way to get to 10 million just off
the kernels. We shall see.
I don't think I'm missing something on
this. So, I'm pretty damn sure
This is where my um this is where my
math bites me a little bit.
Not even math. This is just like
I find this type of stuff very
unintuitive.
Does this work though?
Did you get
I'm wondering if this is like a standard
thing though where they have um
cuz like for the sequences are not going
to be massive.
Yeah, it's annoying because there is
something here. I actually don't even
know though if this is going to be
better on the small sequences.
Let me grab a drink and tell the dog to
go shut up. One second.
Oh, let me look at this first.
Oh,
maybe you can.
Sigmoid Pro.
Oh no, just move this.
Okay, we'll try this real quick. I don't
know if this is good. Um because the
thing is so all this is doing is it's
launching additional threads to do the
um the first chunk up here. It's
launching additional threads to do this.
But I actually don't know.
Let me get my thoughts for it and I'll
explain. It's a little weird. We'll also
just be able to try it in a moment.
We don't necessarily need to. I don't
actually know if the full algorithm
would be faster
for the se length
difficult I've worked on other than nmo.
Um,
honestly like Neural MO is just so much
harder than the rest of them. Like it's
not even close.
So I could pick like a medium complexity
end.
But like
as for big ones, neural MMO is just kind
of blows everything else out of the
water.
What? What?
What the heck?
I don't know why the hell you do it that
way. Uh we'll let we'll see that because
we're just going to test this and revert
it anyways.
That's not going to give you something
useful.
I didn't know that existed. Is this good
though?
It links us to this.
Yeah, this is all getting reverted, I'm
sure, in a second.
Didn't it only changed this one, right?
Yeah. Okay.
So, we will see.
That's so slow.
Yeah, that's so slow. That's [ __ ]
Okay, let's get rid of that crap.
Get rid of this crap.
Yeah. This is why you don't just like
buy [ __ ] cuz it's like it's dumb, right?
Yeah, I think what we want to do is we
basically just want to do what we did
before where we launch the full set of
threads and then we just subset for the
scan.
Can't sync across blocks in one kernel.
Can't sync across blocks.
Hang on.
Let's see if this makes sense. I don't
think so.
Like it drives me nuts that you can't
just find the
so
blocks threads. Yeah.
blocks and threads
blocks threads zero. Yes,
blocks
size.
Yeah. So it gets blocked.
This
Yeah. So, in order for this thing to
scale nicely,
Well, hang on a second.
The way I have this damn thing now,
right?
Look, the way that I have this damn
thing
Uh, add a chess set of positions to
train
text file.
I mean, you can do that for sure jazz. I
just don't know like there's not a nice
way to integrate it into the main
library. obviously
distribute those positions across the
games.
Oh, okay. I see. So, not training like
supervised but training from state
um like starting positions.
Yeah, you would just do it um kind of
like the way that we have our mazes
done, but from file
Yeah, this is actually a tiny number of
threads. What this is right?
I mean, all we want to do
I think this will work.
Doesn't scale great. It'll scale way
better than Puffer 3 still.
And this inside is correct. Yep. This is
what I have.
And this is really the last thing that
needs to be fixed. So,
Yeah. You do this one
and then you sequential scan. Yes.
Yeah, market.
Yes. This is where we're starting to
like
flounder with it a little bit.
And it's because I'm off of my It's like
And it's not cuz I'm off the manifold of
the LM or some [ __ ] It's because
I'm off of my own
This is kind of a weird thing to off to
think about.
I'll let it I'll let it play with this.
But I think this is the slow one.
Fixing some thought. Fixing some things
first.
We're going to get our perf.
and I'm pretty sure I'm correct on this.
So the idea here, right, is that
we just want to do the first chunk of it
full in parallel and then do a thread
sync. So everything is still loaded into
memory and we use a subset of the
threads to compute the uh the final loop
and it's just kind of being pretty
stupid.
Oh, okay. I see.
Yeah, I see. Hang on.
Can't sink across blocks.
It's very awkward to do this in two
launches.
Try this. Hey Peru,
welcome.
I don't know if you've seen the latest
back. We've got it pretty dang clean. It
um it took a lot, but it's it's nice and
stable, at least um for what I've been
using it so far.
for viewers here. Peru wrote uh the
first version of the new VE and it was
very very helpful in uh getting it up
and running.
I'm gonna let it try some stuff here
because I
I'm going to be able to test the speed
afterward, I think. So, autograd and
torch is like awful awful, right?
Like I don't want this to go to two
autograd pops.
In fact, I think it was the chunk
backwards was the really bad one,
Oh, and in fact, yeah, it's even better
because we can just put both of the
launches in like this. That's actually
Yeah, we'll put both launches in there
and then uh we don't even have to edit
the module, which is good.
Few
new improvements at GPU multi-threaded
wait multi-thread vacuum few kernels
without params previous LSTM cell
uh what have you done wait 4.5 mil on a
2080 it's quite good
you if you're optimizing the LSTM cell
though you're going to have a rough time
uh if you link me though on the Discord
or whatever like wherever I Go check it.
Okay, there. That's fine.
Uh, yeah. Tell me where to look in here.
X is low. Let's see. So I puffer lip
cuda kernels.
Oh, did you write
Wait,
there's no way you beat their LSTM
kernel, right?
Like that's actually a really optimized
like KudnN kernel
This I'm actually interested in what
you're doing because you have
wait dual linear forward.
But wait then are you going to still use
Oh, you pulled the internals. Cool.
Then that'll be a KDN call
sample object kernel.
Is this dumbbell?
You have a lot of stuff in here.
I'd like to be able to check some of
this.
Wait, where's this double? Where are
these come from? Dual linear forward
kernel.
Where are the kernels?
in one kernel that does log problems. So
that one is nice.
That one's actually nice. Yeah, dual
linear does values plus decoder.
But when you say it does it, where's the
uh where's the kernel for this?
Or do I am I blind?
Oh, here it is.
Wait, this is a manual mat hole though,
dude.
This is not using the um this is not
using tensor course. I guess for values
and decoder it doesn't matter as much.
Um probably if like the number of
actions is small
this is not using tensors though for
sure.
Number of ops doesn't matter. Are you
testing stuff draft though as well? So
I've been kind of at this for the last
several weeks and there's a whole bunch
of stuff you have to do to test perf on
these things. Um,
so you can check the per operation
times,
but then you also have to check it
graphed because if you're not graphing
it, you're going to count launch times
on top of the uh memory bandwidth
overhead
using MM activm
activation out.
profiling added plus me profiling.
What did you use? Wait, what do you mean
to the pie? Did you use the torch one?
The torch one's really bad.
wait. What?
Where's the thing?
R Liy
plus memory profile.
Okay.
So, if it's this,
Okay. So, for there's there's been some
new stuff on the profiling since we've
been here last time. Um, I did a whole
segment not being able to get good
enough profiling results out of torch
and also profiling at the torch level is
not great anyways.
So, what I did here
So, we've got this uh kernel profile
script. This does a raw CUDA profile
with NSIS and it also does the torch
bind versions and it also does the C++
torch versions.
Let's
say this one
Tried cudigraphs. Cudigraph makes a big
difference.
It was a pain in the ass to figure out.
It defeats the purpose. It uses extra
Alex.
Wait, what?
How does it use X for Alex?
You trace it and then you replay it,
right? And then it just replays the
exact graph.
How do you only have 52 chronal
launches?
Oh, I suppose you have the LSTM.
Copy the correct every segment. Copy.
Yes, you need that's not an ALEC. It's
it's a copy. Uh you can do it directly
if you want. Like you could do it
directly from the end, but I think we
have an intermediate buffer at the
moment. But we got like 2 three millions
SPS out of um CUDA graphs.
You've got a lot of stuff here and I
want to look through it. Um maybe let me
fill you in a little bit on what we've
been doing here so that you can have
some uh some context. So
we now have like custom kernels for
mining grew which is at least
substantially more seek parallel than
LSTM.
Um and from our experiments it seems
like we're getting comparable learning
as well. uh we have training up to 8
point some odd million uh with parameter
and flop match to the LSTM architecture.
We needed to cuda graph trace everything
and we also uh you need to just fuse a
ton of little operations.
I'm almost done with the kernels for
this custom net. I think that there are
still some other ones
uh probably like action sampling and
other stuff like that that I want. So
you actually probably have that there.
Uh actually even fusing stuff like the
value function and and such that
actually might help as well cuz like you
just need to get down the total number
of things happening. Now I will say that
for just pure launch overhead right you
kill that very nicely with cudigraphs. I
tried very hard to get around doing this
but it really does seem like you just
can't. Um every single little thing you
do is a separate launch otherwise.
Um,
so you really need both. From what I've
uh I've seen, I think we're going to be
able to hit 10 mil just off of these
chronal optimizations. And I think we
could get even faster with a few more
fusions.
I'm trying to think about outstanding
stuff. I mean, I'd love to have some of
your the stuff you've been working on uh
on the latest 40. Like, if you can start
playing around and seeing if you can
speed up this with some of your stuff,
that'd be awesome.
Don't understand the train loop only on
the value. Yeah.
Yeah. You kind it need they both need to
be like they both need to work
right like the problem. Okay. So the
problem with the LSTM architecture is
not an evaluate. It's in training
because the LSTM the map moles are
iterative right over the train loop. You
can't do them parallel. So mining lets
you have parallel mode training. It lets
you do all the mat moles in one step.
Try out. I'm having very bad luck with
run pad. Uh I we only got 15090 that I'm
using at the moment. I can get you some
uh I can get you uh 4090s though for
sure.
Does anybody anybody watching knows what
boxes we have open right now? We should
have several.
Very bad luck with a run pod and vast.
Uh, do I have the Are you already on the
cluster or not?
That ends the learning part is bother
with improving learning for my stuff.
Yeah. Well, I mean, our kind of our core
assumption in everything, right, is that
we just like we make the M's fast.
If the M's aren't fast, you're screwed
no matter what you do.
Nope. Okay. So, I can get you uh there's
a user agreement I have to send you.
Eval any reasonable MVL plus M is 95.
That is not true. Yeah, that is not
true. We build fast M's for clients and
it's 0% time at the end. And then Eval
is like 25%.
Honey Puff zero. Oh [ __ ] Are I didn't
know that you're on that one.
I put somebody else with a couple
experiments on that one cuz all the GPUs
looked idle. You can go uh reclaim them
later.
Mostly just for today. Anyways, I can
move I can move those on to Tiny Puff
One.
Try and my end like puffer drive wait my
end like no puffer drive is not um
like puffer drive is also can be fast
right
so puffer drive right now it's mostly um
bandwidth overhead and that'll be cut
out in puffer 4 like we're going to have
that thing well over a million steps per
second training actually the only reason
they're at 300k right now is because
they have a really janky encoder
Even like neural MMO, we're going to
have million plus.
Why a random GPU is active? Yeah, my bad
about that, Jess. Uh, [laughter]
forgot on that one. We'll we'll have to
move some stuff. Uh, is Wait, did I did
I put anybody on Tiny Puff one? I'm
trying to think why I would have put you
on zero when that's usually the one I I
run stuff on.
Is anybody on one?
I mean, I actually ideally the best
thing would be if we could give him a
single GPU box because he doesn't need a
C a six GPU box to test out. The six GPU
boxes are for running heavy experiments.
All good. Do I have you on Discord,
Peru? I can send you the form. It's just
like a sign here saying you won't do bad
things on my cluster.
Speeds up blaster pong and breakout.
Go find the the user form.
We'll get you a GPU.
Where's your thingy?
Uh, what's your
I thought I already had you on here. Why
don't I have a DM on
on Discord?
Most important Wait, most important
speed up though is by multi-threaded GPU
batching, not just M. So obs paralyzed
with CU. Wait, ops
action copy
is paralyzed with the crud kernels along
with the amps. The main readme has all
the wait
not just the wait GPU batching. So the
obs and action copy
is paralyzed
along with the M's. Is this different
from the thing that what we have where
like um you just want to have the stuff
copied onto the GPU
by the time uh you need it.
Evalid torch.
Okay, I got to read this as well now. Uh
what what's your user on Discord? I'm
not seeing your messages.
Let me rebuild this real quick.
I just said hi on Discord. Where is it?
Hang on.
Did you at me on the channel or
something?
Oh, I see. Yeah.
Hang on.
Here we go.
Here's your ula.
I'll get you um I'll get you on this.
What I'll do is I'll get you access and
then you're going to have to get you're
going to have to figure out from the
Discord which of these boxes is open. Um
so you can run some experiments
either like Spencer or B or um Somebody
should know.
Yeah, I really don't care that much
around um about credentials to be
honest. It's
as long as you're doing cool stuff
around here, I give people access.
So if you're not Yes, but not in the way
people were expecting.
Okay, this is crap. Um, let me go look
at the kernel.
Wait,
how can that possibly be slower?
Yeah, the thing is the interface for it
really sucks. Um,
it's very very difficult to make sure
you're using it in a way that you're not
just handing it control of everything.
Okay, where did my where did my timings
go? 32 micros is slow.
Uh but this is with additional stuff
used in right.
It's probably just a me bandwidth,
right?
Advent as code
later sign agreement. Let me send you
the
hang on. Let me put this away in my
folder.
Thank you.
And let me get you your credentials.
I think it has to be It's like really
annoying because I think it has to be
fused, right?
I'm trying to think how badly this thing
scales.
block synchronization problem. Yeah,
super memory bound.
This is why CUDA graphs don't help,
right?
So I'm I'm trying to figure this thing
out. So we need
just really understand this. I want to
make sure I'm not just fundamentally
so basic, but I think I could be messing
something else
within each block.
Number of block starts per block, right?
Well, then hang on. I'm not sure I know
what the hell I'm doing here.
Oh, because it's still parallel over
hidden, right?
tried adding this message on Twitter.
Uh if there was another message, I do
not see it.
So, this is basically going back to what
I had before.
We're doing code reviews. I added a PR
that speeds up Puff Advantage kernel.
Uh, Puff Advantage kernel is like 1.5%
of our runtime, but we'll gladly take
it.
Wait, what?
This is plus 465 lines somehow.
Okay. And then the actual changes are
smaller, right? Yeah.
Load four star.
Load four elements at once.
Huh.
I mean this is probably what we need the
thing I'm doing right now as well, isn't
it?
Interesting. Well, I will have this
merged. Let me play with this. Actually,
let me finish this optimization and then
maybe play with this in the kernel I'm
working on now. This might even be
helpful here.
Okay, this is all the same. So, this is
just the stuff that we had before.
Uh, I'm going to have to figure out what
the heck is doing with this. But yeah,
this is too much flaw for reference.
This is definitely too much flaw. I'm
only doing this because we have
verification.
Um,
but I think I'm going to go back to the
original version after this and then try
to like iterate from there using what
I've learned.
That's saying if it works. Not
particularly because this is like a few
lines of code off of the thing that we
had to begin with FBR.
It's just that it's it looks like a big
change cuz it made a mess in the middle.
Yeah, we definitely don't want two
kernels.
Because now we have Hang on.
How many do we have?
Yeah. So now we don't have enough
because see now it's
Let me use the restroom real quick. I
can actually The good news is though, if
this screws it up, I'm just going to go
back to the version we had before. And
it's actually a pretty small change. I
just I had it backwards originally. I
was making the wrong number of blocks.
And I think it should get us something.
Uh, and definitely the bandwidth is the
big issue here. So right.
Each thread stay active. Yes. Three time
steps.
Okay, this is messing things up at this
point. So
expect that we're just going to test the
design and then revert.
This is excellent example of like
doing too much [ __ ] and making a mess.
wait. I think it undid the mess. Hang
on.
Oh, it's stupid. I see. It just went
back to literally the exact same thing
from before.
I'm trying to think of what because now
this stupid thing has me confused too.
Um,
hold on. It's B * H.
Uh,
yeah. This is actually going to be fine.
Oh, I think these actually these need to
be blocked way better, don't they?
Yeah, the blocks have too little work.
Most likely
too little and too much work.
It's funny.
Well, now I'm not having as much of a
good time of it because I'm being lazy.
It stops being good the second you get
lazy.
I think we go back to the previous dip
in a moment.
Yes, you shouldn't need this [ __ ]
Emerald ship.
Yeah, I'll let it do this, but then
we're going to end up reverting it
because I think this is going to be
super slow and way over complicated.
And then what we'll do is we'll go back
to the version that we had that was
naively fused.
We'll see if there's some load
optimizations or something we can make
there.
Actually, I'm curious.
We look at this PR that we just got.
Where's the PR?
10x speed up here.
This is actually what we have.
So, possibly we can do this.
Yeah, we're going to completely report
this crap so bad.
And then it's basically it'll either be
the two kernel one with optimized loads
or it'll just be the single kernel one.
But we can't have it at ADMS.
See, it's the same freaking speed. Okay.
Uh, let's do
Let me go check the current version that
we have.
estimate the speed up. Uh, no. Because
if I give you some number on this, it's
going to be a big overestimate for other
work.
Like there's going to be stuff where
it's legitimately is 10x, but then
there's also going to be stuff like
really important stuff where it's
basically nothing.
The thing that's stupid about it is the
speed up is mostly a function of how
like bloated and crap the codebase is
that you're working on, right?
Optimizing memory.
I'm optimizing several things. Memory
bandwidth is one of them.
We probably shouldn't even have freaking
shared memory here, honestly.
We probably shouldn't even have this
here.
They have really shitty limits from what
I've heard.
Well, we have this it's a shitty layout.
Like
it's it's kind of weird because like
none of these ops are actually
intensive,
but we have one thing that's purely
sequential and then the other thing
that's full parallel.
It's like a weird in between thing.
I mean, is this really that much work to
ask
end up getting t
you end up with a constant factor
difference.
I think it's better though because if
you do the prefix thing later
actually seems very lucky to me. I think
this design was way closer.
I definitely understand what's going on
a lot better now.
So I don't understand why this thing
why is this not
it shouldn't be sequence size.
Well, that's weird though because then
that's like implying it's max.
If I just comment this thing though,
right? Like
Such cuda.
I could also just go look
We have hardware up we can take
advantage of or no
speed.
Is there like are there ops that just
like do this
X on a few things or something?
Yeah, I know these these are just bath
versions.
Yeah, I was looking for a version. No,
they don't have this full.
Uh, it's a lot of math.
I think we have it right. It's just like
So, it's annoying because we have
this piece is technically parallel,
but anything I've tried to like do this
in parallel and sync it, it's just uh
the same speeder slower.
So, this op here is eating 50 micros.
The rest of it's eating 30 micros.
times faster. Yeah, but this is also the
function that blows up if you do it
wrong.
So,
we can go to that, but I think we can
get it faster before we get there.
Does that just work? Think
it Yes.
I don't think that this totally helps
though because we still have this thing.
It's it's still slow
catch.
It's a little bit obnoxious because it's
like
it's not elementwise, right? Like this
chunk here could be elementwise, but
then the rest of it is not. like this
stuff can't be done element wise
in line actually do anything.
Um,
it makes me know that I'm not
accidentally introducing overhead by the
compiler doing something stupid.
Probably the compiler is smart anyways,
but I don't know.
Is it going to ride over?
Oh, it's in backward though.
cashes
maybe not by default.
I think that's a more NCU
if you want that.
again right so FP16 BF16
these aren't using tensor cores these
are gate operations so you don't even
get a chance to take advantage of that
hardware and these are the most
numerically sensitive operations in the
network
so
If anything, you'd want to stick the
maples in B16.
It works. Yeah. But what happens if it
works and then it [ __ ] crashes your
training run randomly like on a bunch of
experiments?
I don't think like it's not going to be
as big of a perf gain either.
Like this does not let us use tensor
cores if we do it here.
These are gate operations.
Yeah, that doesn't help at all. Cool.
It's not load bound.
That's got to be There's got to be
something for this, right?
that identity.
Well, cuz we're computing both, right?
Well, that's a gross thing that it ends
up doing.
Um, the way that this gets put into
gate. Hang on.
Lots of improvements. We're at 8.8
million steps per second last stretch.
Yeah, these are all like very small
optimizations here at this point.
See that guy? Yeah, we got We got
several profiles. Um,
it's tough.
Everything's pretty tight.
Just very annoying expensive gau
honestly.
Well, I guess there are a few other
things I wanted to check before I spend
a huge amount of time on this.
I think what we'll just do
comment this one.
So we're going to just understand that
there's a little bit more overhead than
there should be here. So I don't have to
deal with this chips.
This is just a quick test.
If this gets more than a few hundredkund
maybe
not massive pretty variable
not massive
flat profile as we expect. Super
annoying to deal with flat profiles.
We have a couple other things we can do.
Yeah, again like another 200ish K
very small.
So we have micro optimizations we can
make.
cuz somehow the freaking
everything has so much over it, man.
I mean, the Mulan step should be allowed
to take a little bit of time, but
I think this goes over 10 just with
this, right?
8.9.
Okay.
We're going to get an end prop out of
this.
My thing is there's still like all this
massive element wise crap
that probably mostly comes from uh the
optimizer frankly.
But I haven't looked at this in a while
with fresh eyes.
and then I think I get myself a refill
on my tea
and we consider what to do from here.
So we have 38.9 actually spent in Matt
moles which is better than before.
It's a much nicer profile than before,
at least.
So, these bad boys are from the
optimizer being a pain.
These kernels are actually pretty big
now, aren't they?
Colonel is
Yeah. Okay.
The thing is it's like such a flat
profile at this point. Does this give us
something reasonable?
Okay. Not significant overhead from this
clip. It's It is from Muan.
I'm going to go use the restroom real
quick and then we will continue. Um, we
got 10% here. We got 10% in the kernels.
We got like little bits of perf floating
elsewhere. If we were at like 96 97, I'd
just start like cleaning stuff up and
doing micros. But I think we're just a
little bit too far off. Like we need one
more actual optimization and then we can
just do micros.
Anti-inovation.
Yeah. No, I the company's freaking
mental hospital. I'll be back.
Okay,
so
We may as well do the fuse scan. It gets
us a couple hundred SPS. We'll try this
thing first. Um,
the heck is this?
Huh?
That even makes sense.
I'm highly doubting this, but we'll try
this.
Yeah, I'm not wasting mental bandwidth
on this because um I'm already on the
next thing in my head. I think that this
is actually this OP is implemented
correctly and it's just like genuinely
some overhead. You pay 10% for Muan.
Muan is worth 10%. It's fine. We don't
worry about it. I think that's what it's
going to be.
Um,
See, but if it's going to be a different
approximation, yeah, I saw this. if it's
a different approximation. The problem
is this requires me to rerun all the
experiments and stuff.
Oh yeah, this one is not going to help
either.
Yeah, this one is not going to like
super help either.
It's more for bigger mats.
Yeah, good job. Uh that is way slower
as you would Effect.
Yeah. So, this got this has to get
loaded in.
It's something like this. We'll figure
it out.
I think we also have numeric on this
problem. We'll see.
9 mil.
Okay,
we're unstable now. That is the problem.
I guess at least now we can rerun this
little profile.
Yeah.
I just want to basically I want to see
how many of these little small ops go
away.
There like way too many little element
wise ops everywhere. It's just a flat
profile, right?
Okay. So, this is fine. That this is a
double.
Is it?
I actually don't know
because this gets cudigraph trace,
doesn't it? Oh, yeah. No, but this shot
doesn't. So, we're good.
all these tiny little element wise
kernels. Yeah.
Oh, you know what though?
Hang on. Let me think.
Yeah. So, the thing I'm not sure is it
just it selects some rows to do the iter
on. Um
like it's already it's already like I
think four nanoseconds per matt. They're
just a lot of them.
I think the better thing is if we could
figure out some way to batch it.
Probably there's something that could be
done with a batch map.
that song
for me.
Here's a forward and backward kernel in
1%
How long does it take to get lean
muscular if you're skinny with high
metabolism?
I've been training about 5 years.
It depends if you want to be healthy or
you just want to be like or you just
want muscle
because if you run as well, if you're
actually getting good cardio, it takes
much longer.
It took me like
I think threeish years to hit um one,
two, three, four, starting at a body
weight of 140 and then getting up to
like 175.
Um,
but then it took me
it took me like another two years of
running
before I was able to do reasonable
distances. And I think now it's been
like three,
yeah, probably three yearsish of
running. Um, where, you know, I can
pretty easily I can do training blocks
for marathons within six weeks. Um, I've
got a better 5K time than I had in high
school, even though I'm 40 lbs heavier.
So, it takes time. You can do it.
It's definitely worth it, though. It's
like the one thing that actually is
always worth it.
13559. Yeah. So, that's basically where
I started. Um,
just go grab, well, it's up to you if
you care about be like muscle versus
strength versus cardio. I just go grab
strong lifts or I mean your super basic
program is you do um five sets of five
bench, squat, deadlift, split them up
over the week, twice a week each,
deadlift only once.
Add an overhead somewhere probably with
squats.
just getting some basic compounds in and
actually eating. You'll put on like 20
pounds in a year
42.
I mean, I could have chosen 007.
short guy going to 140. Yeah, that's way
over my max.
My best was 265 pounds, which is what,
like 120ish maybe.
known as D. I didn't train that early,
man. I only started doing weights when I
was in my 20s.
When I was a teenager, I was like not a
great athlete, but you know, I could
play squash. I could run um 2 miles 14
minutes, and I could do probably around
15 pull-ups. That was about it.
So
is the fish
the fish like this guy.
Also for folks watching please star the
puffer on GitHub if you haven't already.
We're almost at 5,000 stars. Um, that
would be awesome. That' just be awesome.
Jeez. All right, what do we do from
here?
We're kind of out of easy stuff to
optimize.
Uh you can use them for some stuff. If
you outsource your thinking to them,
you're an idiot. And no, software
engineering has been over for in six
months for the last three years. People
are dumb.
Yeah, we don't have RMS form. Stupid
model
Yeah, they're like a couple small
sources.
How is this slower? Oh, it's not. It's
fine. We're at nine. Cool.
or C++ is awful. So I'm not advocating
this [ __ ] either.
I mean I the best thing I can do is like
try to save some stuff off the colonels
a little bit.
X X XT being symmetric.
Yeah, it's the gram matrix, right? Isn't
it?
If there's a kernel for this iteration
that I don't know about, by all means,
but
I don't know about anything.
There's 10% in Muan. There's um 10% in
this kernel somewhere. And then there's
like another 10ish% floating around
somewhere just like with a bunch of
little much smaller things.
We only need to calculate the upper
triangle and copy it.
Uh then you would think there would be a
kernel for that, right?
Funny enough, I don't see anything
exploiting that.
probably because the hardware is just so
optimized for matt malls.
Kind of dull.
Let's see.
Yeah, this is what I thought you could
do. Let me make sure.
Um, I'm just trying Well, at the moment
I'm cleaning this kernel up a little
bit, but then I'm also trying to get
some uh squeeze a little bit of PF out
of it. And then ideally, I think I
should be able to do the same here.
I don't really think there's too much
coming from all this branching, though.
I did measure it before, but there's not
too much else we have that we can
optimize at the moment. And these are a
mess anyways.
Oops.
Let's see. So,
stupid thing
we do move this
Yes, you can kill this branch. You can
kill this branch.
75 micros.
This kernel uh this test has a few
micros worth of play in it. So,
it probably shouldn't,
but it does.
the opinion of it not ch uh changed at
all since the not brain dead not brain
dead vibe coding? Yeah, it's pretty much
if you outsource your thinking to it,
you're an idiot.
Um,
it's useful especially for work that's
very very heavily redundant
like
just the fact that CUDA kernel's bound
to torch with all these additional
things flying around. It's very verbose.
You have to copy stuff in a bunch of
places uh guaranteed.
It saves a lot of time because of that.
It's good for some other things as well,
but you definitely don't want to like if
you're surprised by the code it's
writing, you're doing it wrong. I think
that it's you should generally your goal
should be that it writes exactly the
code that you have in mind.
Like you want to train that loop so that
like you get you would say, okay, this
is the code that I want. This is how I
think it it's going to be implemented.
And if it gets the exact code you would
have written but faster, that's good.
If it comes up with something surprising
and diverges from your expectation,
that's bad.
numerical stability. That's that's what
this is for. We have more aggressive
checks than this, but the current test
is just does it train breakout.
Um I think that this is a better check
than just doing the like the single
iteration ones because I've had those
failed like those succeed before and
this fail.
So actual training is pretty good.
Yeah. So, this is going to come out of
the this is going to be up top, right?
could just be trying to outsmart. I'm
not because I'm also cleaning it up at
the same time.
I think this is better, right?
Let's double check. Oh, yeah.
Oh, wait. Hang on.
Oh, that's awful. No, that's [ __ ]
awful. What are you doing?
I'll run it for the memes to see if it's
faster.
If it's faster for these small maps,
then by all means,
symmetric rank K. But it's not. Is it
symmetric rank K?
That would be if we wanted low ranker
procs to uh
low ranker procs
theoretically should be 50 but it's it's
going to change the numeric right
cuz like we're not doing a low ranker
proc right
I don't know why I did this. Hang on. I
was supposed to build the profiler.
So, I expect that this is not any faster
and this is a mess.
It's slower and a mass. Lovely.
Yeah, we're undoing that [ __ ]
faster gem for AAT.
If it works for
I think our matrices are size 128 by 384
if you wanted to test it out. If it's
faster, that sounds great.
50% speed up gets us um I don't know
probably 4 500,000 SPS
Let me see what Let me actually just
tell it what sections I can pull out.
Man, grabs just get like unintuitively
messy. Okay.
See, the obnoxious thing about this,
right, is it's like
The thing is it's still going to just
all be in. We should just do a test to
see if I comment this line how much we
save.
So because I think this is just clean up
and the rest of it will be perf.
Like it's going to just be save a couple
ops in here and then we'll be good.
Um I'm just going to let it do this and
I'm going to just check it.
Okay. What do we have? We have Yeah. So,
this is what I would have had. See, it's
like it's got more stuff outside of
here.
This is fine. Now, let's see if this is
actually correct.
Well, that means that if like if that
type of a thing can make it slower.
Okay, we'll try this and we'll see if it
restores. If not, we'll go back. Is your
NVIP config open source?
There you go. There's hardly anything in
it.
So, do we get something predictable out
of this or not?
Let's go check this one. I've been
meaning to do this,
which is how much time is in here.
you you want to catch this x if anything
right?
X.
This is hidden,
right?
We save a
tiny.
Yeah, it looks like the re is not
needed, right?
Cuz it's already greater than zero.
I don't even think we'll see it in this.
Yeah, it's in the noise.
It's such a small optimization though.
Like what we would really need.
Oh, wait. If x is greater than zero,
hang on. We can get rid of this.
I would assume that there is a way to do
it, right? Because
you can do it on the forward pass.
Maybe you can do this. I actually that
seems sketchy.
Well, apparently this is a fine
optimization.
Oh, wait. This was not um this was not
remotely close, was it?
Okay. So, let's just keep
let's do this.
Uh, I don't know when the last time you
looked. They are
There's an eval thing at the end.
Okay. So, this is 105. So, this is the
same freaking speed.
And what about with these fast sigmoids?
Does it make a difference?
That doesn't make a damn thing
difference.
We doing this right? It's like so weird
that that doesn't make a difference.
Yeah, like the backwards 44.
This is where it's coming from.
I wonder if we have something done with
this addressing. Hang on.
But the thing is the compiler might like
optimize this out if I do this.
And we'll see.
Slower for small mats, not computebound.
They have fun.
Yeah, everything is tough with very
small mats.
Okay, this is what we're going to try
real quick.
Yeah. I just want to make sure nothing
weird is happening with this.
Yeah, same exact thing. Cool. So we have
sanity.
A news
make sure it's not real. That could do
something.
Yeah, that I would believe could do
just make sure it's these sigmoids real
quick.
the two signals, right? Let's just
check my intuition.
interesting. You actually don't save
that much.
comes if I do this?
How much of the total time the program
is in sigmoids?
like nothing really.
I do this correctly.
Yeah, nothing.
Okay,
No,
it uh it isn't
Re the board pass. Yes, I can. Thank
you.
I'm just interested in this this little
branch right here.
Yeah, you shave quite a bit.
But then I don't understand how.
Like this does not do anything. I I'd be
shocked.
Sol plus negative hidden.
Uh let me look.
Is there a copy by creating a bar
before the if statement?
Um, I think the P we just tested
removing one of them. I think the
compiler gets it.
Yeah, this is the same.
It's surprising to me that this is not
faster. Like
it's very odd.
Been about five hours. I've been
optimizing a lot of stuff.
A lot of stuff.
Uh
lots of very small little things.
LM to do per opt.
Uh, yeah, you can and you can just ask
flawed to try it. It's just not great.
Like, it makes a mess. That's the thing.
Yeah, I know. Cuda doesn't like if else
if.
Do you have a solution that doesn't
involve computing them both? Anyways,
log co and log z from one soft plus.
Wait, you can calculate log co.
Uh that is this right here. But you need
two, don't you?
There three soft pluses in here.
So you can save one of them. I don't
think you can save two
because you also have on you also have
it on the hidden.
Yeah, I got that one pretty recently,
Rob.
It was a very like small little bump.
This one annoys me because like it seems
like you should be able to just clean
this whole thing up, but actually most
of the overfread is in here anyways.
Let me see.
See what this guy sent me.
Wait. Float.
on that one I could believe I could
apply I could believe that the identity
is applied wrong. Whoops.
Uh, did I just block you by mistake? I
hope not.
Something just came up.
Wait. Okay. No, I did not block you by
mistake. Type something to make sure. I
want to make sure I didn't misplay. Yep.
Um, remove the branching.
It's about the same speed. Let me see if
it if it breaks it. It's cleaner either
way. So, let me see if it breaks
something.
I don't see his name on the YouTube
chat. Uh oh. Did I ban him? Let me go
check my list. I might have misclicked
him.
[ __ ]
Hang on.
Let me make sure I didn't screw that up.
I probably did.
where is my freaking ban list? I think I
banned him by mistake.
That's super annoying.
I have a giant ban list from all the
freaking bots.
Actually, I don't see him in here.
I I do not see him in here on the list.
Unless it didn't sink.
Uh, I don't see him on here at all.
Unless my cat just like got screwed up.
Oh, wait. I might have put him on the
YouTube lock list by mistake.
Stupid thing. It's like too easy to
misclick that.
Hang on. Let me just go figure out what
the heck.
I probably Just click block them on
YouTube.
Let me see where it is. New window.
Oh, I don't even have that account
signed in. That's super annoying.
No worries. I joined on X. I did ban you
by mistake. My bad, dude. I I will fix
that. Um
yeah, I have to like go like get the
client signed in and stuff. It's super
annoying that like I can accidentally
rightclick ban people by mistake.
And there's no way for me to even open
the view from here.
Yeah, same person, different account. I
figured
Yep. So, the one that you gave me the
first time is different, man. It's not
numerically correct.
me. Try a couple quick things.
I do this.
Oops.
Probably side quest. Yeah.
messages aren't going through again.
That's not me. That's either X or Reream
filtering.
It doesn't like links. It doesn't like
things that it thinks are spam.
If anybody has a better service than
this, let me know. I will gladly switch.
Let's see. I will grab your
thing. Oops.
I don't know. The freaking paste doesn't
even work from here, man.
It's the new lines.
All right, hang on. Let me go check.
Pretty sure that was the same one that
didn't work.
All right, I get ready in a second to go
get dinner, but um I got to finish this
last couple test from you guys
here.
I'll try I'll test it real quick, but I
don't think so.
Okay, let me try one last thing, guys. I
just wanted to try messing the the
really easy thing. Now that we've done a
bunch of stuff, I want to make sure that
the kernel size just a free free bunch
of perf sitting around here.
Just going to test this and we're going
to go get dinner.
seven. Okay, this is correct, but I
don't think it's faster.
I But the thing is, I don't even think
branching is the main thing. I think
we're like splitting hairs over a couple
micros that aren't going to actually
make a difference.
See, locks gate minus SP gate.
Okay, I think you're probably right that
there is an optimization. You can paste
in the Discord or I can do it after. Let
me just double check one. Oops. What? I
just did this one. And where's the
profiler?
Yeah. So, you don't get anything by
increasing these kernel sizes either.
Um, I'll give you guys the quick rundown
of this and then I'm leaving for dinner.
So, what I've been doing here,
this is a little bit of an annoying
kernel because most of the compute is
right here in the log co-ops and values
which is uh element wise parallel. You
can do it outside the loop, but then you
have this additional scan loop that's
like not entirely trivial um but is
substantially faster.
So
if you split this into two kernels, like
the extra mem bandwidth overhead and
stuff, you get just as slow. If you try
to do a sync in between, like I haven't
been able to get that to be as fast. So
like the simplest thing that is also
fast that I've seen so far is just to do
this and then to try to optimize the
operations as best we can. There's
probably a fair bit you can do here. Uh,
I have a lot of good profiling, but I
don't have profiling down to the level
of like, you know, how much does this X
cost us and stuff like that. So, I think
there's probably we can probably shave a
good bit off of these kernels. And um,
the fuse scan forward plus backward is
like 15% of the program time right now.
Um, the other ones are pretty small and
the only sources of overhead. So, we've
got this, we've got um like 10% for the
Newton Scholes iteration in Muan, and
then we have a whole bunch of
unaccounted for element wise op over
overhead, like another 15 20%. But I
actually can't find it anywhere. Like, I
think it's just a very very flat profile
over the rest of the code where you'd
kind of have to go fuse things in one by
one for, you know, 0.25% 25%
gains per thing that you've used.
So that's pretty much where we are with
this. Um regardless though, right, we
are at
like close to 9 mil train, which is
pretty awesome.
If anybody wants to fix the fused loss
crumb will be 9 mil flat.
8.8 though.
So I think that micros will get us up to
like 9.3 9.4 maybe.
We got to find a couple other things to
get our 10 mil and then you know once we
get our 10 mil we clean up and it's
release time.
Anyways, thank you all for joining me. I
got to go get to dinner. Um I got dinner
with family tonight. No stream tomorrow.
Tomorrow I get some rest. Uh you all can
chat in discord.gg/puffer
if you want. That's the main Discord. If
you all want to help me out for
absolutely free, please just star the
disc uh star the repo on GitHub. We're
almost to 5,000 stars. That will be
awesome to hit that. You can follow me
on X for more content and join Discord,
of